[Music]
yo speaking of
um kim kardashian
everyone makes sure to buy kim
kardashian's crypto
this one's blowing up you guys
absolutely to the moon
absolutely mooning dude this one's a
full moon
people if there's anyone you want to
invest your money into
as far as crypto on the internet you're
going to want to go with the person who
actually
broke the internet yeah kim k
that was tmz jesus christ that was
really good
can you zoom in on this so we can read
it this is when i say we were being an
impressionist prop podcast you weren't i
wasn't even [ __ ] around dude
so uh this is go up to the top
oh yeah okay so this is on kim
kardashian's story from yesterday the
day before
are you guys into crypto this is not
financial advice but sharing what my
friends just told me about the ethereum
max token
a few minutes ago ethereum max burned
400 trillion tokens
literally fifty percent of their admin
wallet giving back
to the entire emacs community and this
is emacs
disrupt history ethereum max what the
[ __ ] emacs
gop emacs ethereum max hashtag ad
swipe up
my friends are just telling me about
ethereum max
yeah it's like ethereum but it's to the
max yeah
bro what is that scammy ass picture
laser tag arena are you joking me are
you guys into crypto
this is not financial advice just some
friends were telling me about ethereum
max
who are your friends that we're telling
you about ethereum my friends at
ethereum max were just telling me about
a theory of acts
my friends at the marketing team of
ethereum max my friends at the ethereum
max discord were telling me about
ethereum max
hello jesus this is kim k kim nice to
meet you we're so excited to have you on
for ethereum max
do you need more money yeah yeah is
there a point where
you're like i'm good you have to do [ __ ]
like this
like i understand if it's a new like
skin like something that like falls in
line with what they've been doing but
like
this is just nothing to do with anything
they've ever been involved with
and she's already has like 300 million
dollars right must be
it's like why does it if so like why
wouldn't you just take a second and be
like
oh this seems sketchy it doesn't seem
like i know anything about this so i'm
probably not gonna dive into it
no why would you why would you do that
ethics yeah no yeah i guess it doesn't
matter anymore yeah no
i mean you're kim k you have all the
money in the world i think it's just a
game at that point
how can you know ethereum max
sure yeah it's like um oh million bucks
okay i'll buy to buy me a trip to the
private island
yeah whatever
how much how do you think she made from
this million bucks probably yeah
bry paid her that would be really funny
if they paid it to her in ethereum max
that would be i mean they probably did
yeah clowned
yeah absolutely owned go to the go back
to the
go to the picture of her car this is
what she bought with her
yeah i love this headline waste of money
kim kardashian wraps her entire 200 000
lamborghini and skims cozy fabric
as fans slam move as stupidest thing
ever
i mean it's actually kind of cool i'm
saying it's like a cool marketing thing
like you could just take it off
yeah yeah yeah no you definitely could
it's not like she ruined her car
sorry i don't think calling something
the stupidest thing ever is really a
slam
yeah something that qualifies as a slam
yeah this is the stupidest thing ever
slam this is literally so dumb
oh slammed again i've never seen
something this
in-name kim kiss got [ __ ] slammed
watch kim k gets slammed this sunday
on tmz her car is the stupidest thing
ever
absolutely slammed
yo i mean it's crazy what what is the
fabric is it it looks
like a giant cotton ball dude it's cozy
it's skim's cozy fabric dude it says it
right there oh i'm an idiot sorry
god oh are you getting top again during
the podcast like focus dude
i'm sorry dude i'm just kidding it's
crazy
wow is that skim's cozy fabric on kim
k's new lamborghini
damn it i wish i wish i had this tick
tock that i saw
damn it i wish i would have sent it it
was really funny yeah so this dude
laying there and he had one of those
like sex dolls on him
okay but it was facing the other way
like the camera he's laying on the couch
like this and his buddy's filming him
from this way and the sex doll is
sitting this way okay
and he just winds up and slaps it in the
face so it looks like a real
like girl oh my god and he slaps him in
the face and the head turns around and
faces the camera it's like this
lifeless sex doll oh just brutal
[Laughter]
oh damn
yeah sorry i just couldn't take my eyes
off the skim's cozy fabric on kim k's
new
lamborghini yeah 200k stupidest thing
ever honestly in my opinion can i see
like
another picture of it or like more video
i'm just blown away by this
oh yeah this would be a good ad oh there
it is bro
what in the hell looks warm
can't drive that in the summer
dude how is anyone mad at this this is
so clearly just like
it's kind of a fabric just cut it's kind
of [ __ ] sick
yeah driving driving a carpet
might be a little hot in the summer
though got him
absolutely slammed absolutely
bet you can't put that one in rice
[Music]
oh all white what about if it rains
better hope no one brings spaghetti in
that thing
can't be drinking red wine while you're
driving i can't anyways
what always blows my mind is no one
outside of her fans like i don't think
anyone really cares about this [ __ ]
so what's crazy is they just put this in
like tabloids like
you know they just kid them up and like
yo we're wrapping a car with this
yeah like that's how we know about it
yeah
yeah we got played you're saying yeah
100
yeah are you into crypto by the way i'm
i just kind of
because my friends were telling me about
this coin ethereum max
oh that's crazy yeah you should check it
out dude
add you should check it out
yeah no
i mean i've only heard positive things
about ethereum max ad
dude my friends tell me it's gonna be a
full moon ad
yeah i agree ad
we have to just say that now after uh
any of our opinions endorsing shout out
to faze jarvis ad
phase ed ben had this hilarious
screenshot of kim's
story it was like uh related to
to pride month and there's a screenshot
of her game it's like it's like
remember she came with that mobile game
a while ago it's a picture of her avatar
you know against uh like
a rainbow and she says happy pride month
i love how there are so many ways to
express yourself in my game
i love that i love that
it's like how do you how how did you
just make pride about yourself
oh my god i'd love to see you all
express who you truly are
in my game in my game i'm reviewing
avatars this saturday
hopefully i'll see yours it's crazy
that's what we don't do enough dude i
have so much pride for
ethereum max
to the moon i have pride for this month
and i have pride for ethereum
we don't do that enough bro we don't
make it about us we don't hijack
movements
yeah we have ethics we need to knock
that off
it's true
just some horrible just hijack some
horrible tragedy
i know the events that have taken place
today are absolutely awful
and we hope that our podcast on patreon
ad free i'd supposed to say we talked
about it
in length and great deal on the bonus
episode of the podcast and you can get
access to that
on our patreon this episode particularly
is
um a hundred dollars yeah just this one
um you can listen to it one time it's
actually an nft right it can't be played
back
yeah use code pride for five dollars off
yeah yeah
so
[Laughter]
use pray for paris as a promo code
damn throwback
you